.
Die Schweiz gilt
als das Wasserschloss Europas.
Doch Wasserknappheit ist in gewissen
Bergregionen bereits Realität.
Wärmere Winter
bringen weniger Schmelzwasser.
Das hat Auswirkungen
auf die Landwirtschaft.
Am Wasser hängt alles,
das ganze Leben.
In einem Gebiet,
in dem es kein Wasser mehr gibt,
wächst nichts mehr.
Bergbauern kämpfen um ihre Alpen,
weil Quellen versiegen.
Ohne Wasser können wir gehen.
Wir können zusammenpacken
und dorthin gehen,
wo es vielleicht noch hat.
Das Schmelzen der Gletscher
bringt im Sommer noch Wasser,
aber nicht mehr lange.
Wenn das so weitergeht,
gibt es in vielleicht drei Jahren
keinen Bach mehr.
Irgendwann versickert es einfach.
Sie alle müssen sich
etwas einfallen lassen.
Snowfarming
könnte im Engadin die Lösung sein.
(Lachend) Das ist ganz schön hoch.
Ich bin auch schon 1,80 m gross.
Also, gut.
Eine kleine Wasserdruckpumpe
soll im Prättigau Abhilfe schaffen.
Ja, ja, ihr seid lustig.
Und im Wallis will man einen Stausee
für die Landwirtschaftsbewässerung
nutzen.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Es ist Mitte Juni im Oberwallis.
Willst du wässern?
Ja, ich könnte es
einige Stunden laufen lassen.
Ja, das sollte gehen.
- Das sollte gehen.
Bis um 18 Uhr kannst du.
- Bis um 18 Uhr kannst du wässern.
Früher war das ganz anders,
man hatte das ganze Jahr
andere klimatische Bedingungen.
Es gab im Winter
auch mehr Niederschläge als jetzt.
Das war ganz anders.
Aber nicht zu lange.
- Nein, nein.
Die Gegend um Salgesch lebt vom
Rebbau und Reben brauchen Wasser,
v.a. zwischen Juni und August.
Regen gibt's wenig in dieser Region,
jeder Bauer darf nur
im Zweiwochenrhythmus wässern.
Ist man nicht an der Reihe,
muss man fragen.
Viele Weinbauern
schalten auf Tropfbewässerung um.
Das braucht weniger Wasser.
Seit rund zehn Jahren
kommt der Gletscher
nicht mehr auf die Walliser Seite.
Das hatte zur Folge,
dass man die ganze Organisation
der Bewässerung ändern musste.
Früher hatte man genügend Wasser.
Man musste sich nicht gross
um die Verteilung kümmern.
Heute hat man durch die Veränderung
des Gletschers viel weniger Wasser.
Jetzt muss man das
viel effizienter organisieren.
Der Fluss Raspille
versorgt das ganze Gebiet.
Jetzt, während der Schneeschmelze,
führt er noch viel Wasser.
Die Brüder Gert und Harald Glenz
sind zuständig
für die Bewässerung der Gegend.
Wasser gab es hier noch nie
im Überfluss.
Vor 40 Jahren hat man darum
ein ausgeklügeltes Bewässerungssystem
mit 40 km Leitungen
in die Rebberge installiert,
um alle gerecht
mit Wasser zu versorgen.
Jetzt muss man das
viel strenger handhaben.
Als der Gletscher noch da war,
hatten wir einen 24-Std.-Rhythmus.
Aber das reichte nicht mehr,
denn die Nachbargemeinden
wollten auch Wasser.
Deshalb musste man
die Bewässerungszeit verkürzen.
D.h., man ging von vier auf
zwei Wochen und von 24 auf 12 Std.
Sodass jeder
ein bisschen Wasser bekommt.
Die Wasserverteilung
steuert Harald Glenz per Handy.
Er ist auch im Gespräch
mit den Gemeinden.
Sein Bruder Gert
ist für die Wartung zuständig.
Dreh stark auf.
(Funk) Ja, in 3 Sek.
Hier unten haben wir jetzt
rund 80, 90 l pro Sekunde,
die in die Reben gehen,
der Rest geht in die Wiesen.
Der Überlauf fliesst ins alte
Bewässerungssystem, in die Suonen.
Sie würden heute
nicht mehr ausreichen,
um die Reben zu bewässern.
Mit dem wenigen Wasser,
das noch kommt,
muss man viel gezielter vorgehen.
Es ist unmöglich,
das mit Suonen zu regulieren.
Früher gab man einander vielleicht
noch mit der Schaufel auf den Kopf,
heute versucht man eher,
es miteinander zu besprechen.
Aber schon vorgängig
und das ganze Jahr.
Man macht eine Besprechung
vor der Bewässerungssaison
und eine Nachbesprechung: Wie ist es
gelaufen, was kann man verbessern?
Im Moment reicht das Wasser dank
umsichtiger Planung noch für alle,
aber es ist auch erst Juni.
* Mystische, glockige Musik *
Die Valzeina im Prättigau.
Die Bauern aus Wimmis sömmern
seit jeher ihr Vieh auf der Alp.
* Lockrufe *
Komm! Kommt!
Reto Dünser ist Bauer,
Gemeindevorstand
und Präsident der Alperza Trimmis.
Er hat Sorgen:
In den letzten drei Jahren sind
viele Quellen hier oben versiegt.
Das Problem ist einfach:
Gegenüber früher haben wir jetzt
einfach schon im April 30 °C.
Zu meiner Jugendzeit
gab es das nicht.
Ein trockenes Jahr gab es immer mal.
Aber das nahm man zur Kenntnis
und im nächsten Jahr
war es wieder anders.
Vielleicht gab es mal
einzelne Quellen,
die kein Wasser mehr führten.
Aber man konnte immer
irgendwie ausweichen.
Aber durch diese warmen Frühlinge
entweicht der Schnee durch die Luft,
statt dass er in den Boden ginge.
Wir können heute in den Socken
auf dem Schneefeld stehen
und bekommen nicht mal nasse Socken.
Und das ist eben nicht ganz das,
was förderlich ist.
Hier, auf dieser unteren Weide,
fliesst im Moment
noch genügend Wasser.
Das braucht es auch
bei 100 durstigen Kühen.
Man sagt, eine Kuh
braucht 10 % des Körpergewichts.
D.h., wenn eine Kuh 600 kg wiegt,
braucht sie 60 l Wasser pro Tag.
Das ist der Normalverbrauch.
Wenn es 30 °C ist, ist es umso mehr.
Dann sind wir
bei 70 oder 80 l pro Tag.
Dann braucht es grosse Mengen
für 100 Kühe.
Zusammen mit Brunnenmeister
Patrick Tönz muss Dünser schauen,
dass das Wasser auf der Alp
für den ganzen Sommer reicht.
Hast du gesehen, wie schnell es
jetzt gegangen ist?- Ja.
Und hier kommt viel Wasser,
aber der Brunnen ist leer.
Gespiesen wird dieser Brunnen von
Quellwasser ein bisschen weiter oben.
Schauen wir mal,
was hier noch kommt.
* Friedliche Gitarren-
und Klaviermusik *
Dieses Wasser ist noch nie versiegt.
Ich kann mich nicht erinnern
und ich glaube,
auch die älteren Trimmiser ...
Das heisst hier das Kaltwasser.
Ich nenne es seit 2018
unser heiliges Wasser.
Das ist das Wasser, das immer läuft
und hoffentlich auch
im nächsten Jahrzehnt noch läuft.
Das Problem haben wir
ab ca. 1'800 m aufwärts.
Die Felsschichtung
läuft schräg zum Tal hinunter.
D.h., was oben an Regen kommt,
rinnt auf den Schichten hinunter.
und kommt irgendwo auf dieser Höhe
hinaus.
Aber oben auf dem Grat,
wo die Tiere lange sind,
fehlt einfach das Wasser,
wenn es keinen Regen gibt.
Die Alperza Trimmis
bewirtschaftet mit 100 Mutterkühen
rund 250 ha Weideland.
In den letzten Jahren
war das Wasser hier oben oft knapp.
Das sorgt immer für Gesprächsstoff.
Das Maximum
waren etwa 3-4 Minutenliter.
Aber jetzt lohnt es sich nicht.
Nein, jetzt im Frühling
ist nichts gekommen.
Wenn es regnet, kommt dort etwas,
aber sonst ...
Wenn es regnet,
hat man genug Wasser.
Wenn ich zurückdenke und es
mit den letzten Jahren vergleiche,
ist das Wasser
brutal zurückgegangen.
Ich meine die aussergewöhnlich
trockenen Sommer, die wir hatten.
Und im Winter gab es einfach
zu wenig Niederschlag.
Denn der Schnee im Winter
ist massgebend,
damit die Quellen im Sommer wieder
aus dem Vollen schöpfen können.
Vor zwei Jahren
war die Situation besonders prekär.
2018 war es schon im Frühling
sehr trocken.
Auch unten im Tal.
Damals
ist praktisch kein Futter gewachsen.
Und äh ...
Das Problem ist:
Wir sind ein Landwirtschaftsbetrieb
mit Tierhaltung.
Im Sommer brauchen wir das Futter
für die Wintervorräte.
Dann wurde es in den Alpen
auch trocken.
An der einen Alpstelle,
dem Zanutscherboden,
ist das Wasser wirklich versiegt.
Dort oben
konnten wir gar nichts mehr machen.
Wir mussten den Helikopter zu Hilfe
nehmen und zehnmal hinauffliegen.
Denn wie gesagt:
Im Tal hatte es auch nichts mehr.
Wir mussten schauen,
dass wir oben weiden können.
Jeder Flug hat 1'500 Fr. gekostet.
Damals kam ich zum Schluss:
Das kann nicht die Zukunft sein, wir
müssen eine andere Lösung suchen.
Das kann kostenmässig,
ökologisch usw. nicht sein.
Wir haben lange überlegt,
was hier möglich sein könnte.
Das Ziel war nicht,
einen Motor laufen zu lassen,
der Strom produziert
und viel Diesel braucht.
Das wäre das Wasser,
das hinunter auf den Wider geht.
Stimmt, ja.
Der Wider ist eine kleine Maschine,
die allein mit Wasserdruck
funktioniert.
Bei der Quelle dort hinten
entnehmen wir das Wasser.
Dann geht es
100 Höhenmeter hinunter.
Dort unten wird der Schacht
mit dem Wider darin gesetzt.
Das ist nötig,
weil eine gewisse Menge Bar
an Druck vorhanden sein muss,
damit wir es
430 Höhenmeter hinaufbringen.
Mit dieser Anlage bringen wir es
auf den höchsten Punkt, auf 2'230 m.
Dort gibt es einen grossen
Rundbrunnen als Reservoir.
Von dort können wir das Wasser
mit dem Überlauf
auf alle Brunnen verteilen.
Das System Wider
gibt es schon 100 Jahre
oder vielleicht noch länger,
ich weiss es nicht genau.
Mir wurde gesagt,
es gebe einen Wider von 1880,
der noch heute laufe.
Mit dem altbewährten Gerät
will die Gemeinde
gleich das ganze Brunnensystem
auf der Alp erneuern.
Auch vom Kanton und vom Bund
gibt es Geld dafür.
Das funktioniert allerdings nur,
weil man hier eine gute Quelle
für die Trinkwasserversorgung hat,
von welcher man Wasser
für den Wider abzweigen kann.
Stossen!
Kommt schon Wasser in den Schlauch,
Reto?- Ja, es kommt.
Es ist einfach faszinierend.
Man macht hier etwas,
das über Generationen ...
Zu Beginn
kostet die Installation usw. etwas,
aber dann haben wir über Jahrzehnte
keinen Aufwand mehr.
* Langgezogene Gitarrenakkorde *
Die Lischana-Hütte im Engadin
liegt auf 2'500 m.
In der nach dem Gletscher
weiter oben benannten Hütte
rinnt praktisch kein Wasser,
obwohl Mitte Juni
rundherum noch viel Schnee liegt.
Ursula Hofer ist seit fünf Jahren
Hüttenwartin hier.
Ohne Wasser geht halt gar nichts,
es ist schwierig.
Den stellen wir jetzt auf den Herd
und warten, dass Wasser daraus wird.
Sie möchte die Hütte öffnen,
aber ohne fliessendes Wasser
geht das nicht.
Jetzt beginnt es zu regnen,
dann kann man auch
die Dachrinne wieder aktivieren.
Im schlimmsten Fall
muss ich den Saisonstart
um drei, vier Tage verschieben.
Bis sich das Wetter so ändert,
dass ich davon ausgehen kann,
dass ich fliessendes Wasser
in der Hütte habe.
Jetzt schauen wir mal,
ob das schon kocht.
Nein, noch nicht. Es hat sogar
noch etwas Schneeschaum obendrauf.
Einmal aufkochen, dann ist er weg.
Ursula Hofer hofft auf Regen.
Sie stellt das Gleiche fest
wie Reto Dünser auf der Alp.
Die Wassersituation
hat sich dahingehend verändert,
dass es
viel weniger Schmelzwasser gibt.
Ich habe das Gefühl,
der Wind nimmt viel mehr Schnee mit,
es verdunstet viel mehr.
Das verändert sich auch nicht,
wenn es wärmer wird.
Es bleibt einfach so wenig.
Wenn es wärmer wird,
geht alles nach oben weg.
Töpfe hin, Töpfe her,
Töpfe hin, Töpfe her.
Wenn das warme Wasser
nicht aus der Leitung kommt,
ist es immer ein riesiges Spielen
mit hin- und herschöpfen.
Es ist doch mehr geworden,
als ich gedacht habe.
Unter der Hütte hingegen
kommt Wasser in rauen Mengen.
Das spärliche Schmelzwasser
versickert oben im Karstgestein
und kommt 400 m weiter unten
zusammen mit Quellwasser heraus.
Felix Keller
beobachtet die Veränderung
der Wassersituation in den Alpen
mit Sorge.
Er ist Glaziologe
und kommt aus der Gegend.
Die Lischana-Hütte und der Gletscher
sind für ihn ein Stück Heimat.
Hallo, Felix.
- Hallo, Ursula.
Bist du auch wieder mal hier?
- Ja.
Lange nicht gesehen.
Woher hast du jetzt das Wasser?
- Vom Dach.
Es hat die letzten Tage geschneit.
Schmelzwasser, Regenwasser.
Jetzt haben wir vier, fünf Kanister
mit 20 l herumstehen.
Jetzt gehst du dich aufwärmen, oder?
- Gut, danke.
Keller ist ETH-Dozent und hat
verschiedene Projekte entwickelt,
um dem zunehmenden Wasserproblem
in den Alpen zu begegnen.
Ich denke, auch in der Schweiz wird
die Wasserknappheit wahrscheinlich
in bestimmten Regionen,
v.a. im Gebirge, eher zunehmen.
Die gefährdetsten Regionen
sind wahrscheinlich das Südwallis
und die Südostschweiz,
also die Region Südbünden,
Unterengadin, Münstertal.
Das sind die trockensten Regionen
im Gebirge in der Schweiz.
Die Lischana-Hütte
liegt in einem solchen Gebiet.
Ursula Hofer
kämpft die ganze Saison um Wasser
und legt dafür Kilometer zurück.
Sie hat drei Wasserfassungen,
die je nach Jahreszeit
ein bisschen Wasser liefern.
Doch die Unterste ist am Versiegen.
Bis vor drei, vier Jahren floss hier
so viel Wasser aus dem Schneefeld,
dass ich die Hütte damit
drei Wochen versorgen konnte.
Du hast gesagt, es laufe.
- Ja, es läuft ganz schwach.
Ja.
- Ich lege ein Gräschen hinein.
Zack!
- Zack, weg ist es!
Ja, ja,
aber es ist halt einfach zu wenig.
Und dort, schau, das ...
- Das gibt keinen Liter pro Minute.
Das trinkt Ceci gleich aus.
* Beide lachen. *
150 Höhenmeter weiter oben
ist die zweite Wasserfassung,
die, wenn der Schnee
rund um die untere geschmolzen ist,
das Schmelzwasser weiter oben
sammelt.
Mit einfachen Schläuchen, die
jetzt noch unter dem Schnee liegen,
wird das Wasser
in die Hütte geleitet.
So funktionieren die meisten
SAC-Hütten in dieser Höhe.
Eine halbe Stunde Fussmarsch weiter
oben: eine weitere Enttäuschung.
Diese Wasserfassung
ist noch vereist.
Zudem ist sie veraltet.
Wasser ist bei uns ein so
selbstverständliches Gut geworden,
dass wir manchmal vergessen,
dass Wasser
durch gar nichts ersetzbar ist.
Hier kommt das Rohr aus dem Schacht.
- Ja.
Im Sommer versorgt
der Lischana-Gletscher weiter oben
die Hütte mit Wasser.
Aber der wird in ein paar Jahren
weggeschmolzen sein.
Darum will Felix Keller testen,
ob man Schnee als Wasserreserve
für den Sommer speichern kann.
Snowfarming nennt man diese Methode.
Mit seinem Sohn und dessen Kollegen
deckt er Schnee
neben der Wasserfassung
mit einem Vlies zu.
Das ist eher
ein wissenschaftliches Experiment.
Wir wollen schauen, ob wir
mit einem kleineren Eingriff -
das ist ja keine grosse Fläche -
genügend Wasser speichern können,
sodass die Hütte auch noch im Herbst
vom Schneeschmelzwasser
profitieren kann.
Gut!
- Ja.- Ja.
Snowfarming wird im Moment
in verschiedenen Gegenden diskutiert.
Denn darauf,
dass die Gletscher verschwinden,
muss man sich früh genug einstellen.
Ich glaube, die Einstellung,
wir hätten die Natur
vollständig im Griff,
kam erst
in den letzten 20, 30 Jahren auf.
Ich finde es gut,
dass wir wieder lernen,
dass wir der Natur gehorchen müssen
und nicht die Natur uns.
Wenn das Experiment funktioniert,
wäre das eine beständige Lösung für
ein grosses Problem, auch anderswo.
Zwei Monate später.
Es ist Mitte August.
Im Oberwallis fehlt Wasser,
obwohl es kein aussergewöhnlich
heisser Sommer war bisher.
Die Situation ist so,
dass wir momentan
aus beiden Speisungen
kein Wasser mehr haben.
D.h., von der Raspille
haben wir kein Wasser mehr
und von der Gemeinde Varen
haben wir auch kein Wasser mehr.
Wenn wir das nicht irgendwie lösen,
entsteht ein gewisser Druck
auf das Trinkwassernetz,
wenn sie die Umgebung wässern.
Das wäre ganz schlecht.
Das Trinkwassernetz wird unabhängig
und von einer Quelle im Dorf
gespiesen.
Aber für die Landwirtschaft
sieht es schlecht aus.
Zum Glück ist die Zeit, in der die
Reben regelmässig Wasser brauchen,
vorbei,
denn jetzt fehlt das Gletscherwasser.
Ja, da ist nicht mehr viel.
Das wird sich auch nicht bessern
in nächster Zeit.
Frühestens im November, wenn es
vielleicht wieder mal schneit,
wird es sich verbessern.
Aber sonst
wird sich das nicht mehr ändern
in den nächsten zwei, drei Monaten.
Klar, wenn es
alle fünf, sechs Tage regnet,
könnte man es überbrücken.
Aber das ist natürlich ...
Deshalb sind wir noch katholisch.
Hier geht man in die Kirche beten,
dass es Wasser gibt.
Das ist das Wenige, das noch kommt.
Die Nachbargemeinde Varen
hat noch Wasser vom Fluss Dala.
Harald beauftragt seinen Gemeinderat,
abzuklären,
ob Varen aushelfen könnte.
Ja, salut.
Gut? Ja.
Ja, das haben wir ja vereinbart:
13 Rp.
Gut, die Preise ... Ja.
Ja, ist gut. Ich schaue mit ihm.
Okay, danke, tschüs, tschau.
(Seufzend) Ja.
Das muss jetzt koordiniert werden,
dann sollte das hoffentlich
wieder etwas korrigiert werden.
Aber ... Ja, es ist im Moment
gerade überall knapp.
Statt Mittagspause -
Warten auf Wasser.
Auch Nachbar André Oggier würde
gerne seine Jungpflanzen wässern.
Ein Teil des Wassers der Dala
wird in Varen turbiniert.
Ich hatte mit ihnen Kontakt
und sie versuchen jetzt,
die Turbine etwas zu drosseln
und uns Wasser hinunterzuschicken.
Aber das ist natürlich auch ein
System, das sich ausgleichen muss.
Mal schauen, ob das funktioniert.
Aber wenigstens ist die Hoffnung da,
dass vielleicht etwas kommt.
Sie schauen jetzt, dass sie uns
Wasser von der Dala geben können.
Pascal hat mir gesagt,
sie könnten nichts geben.
Ja, er macht das jetzt.
Gut, dann gehen wir nachher schauen.
Sie beschliessen nachzuschauen,
ob die Verbindungsleitung
zwischen Varen und Salgesch
richtig funktioniert.
Super.
Er hat jetzt
etwas mehr Druck gegeben,
sodass ihr Netz ein Übermehr macht.
Dieses Wasser können wir brauchen.
Dann ist das gut.
- Tipptopp.
Jetzt muss er noch das Netz füllen.
Aber wenigstens haben wir Wasser,
das ist schon viel wert.
Dann gehen wir mal schauen.
40 km Leitung zu füllen
dauert eine Weile.
Aber selbst dann erhalten nur jene
Wasser, die Vieh tränken müssen.
Um den richtigen Turnus zu machen,
bräuchte ich sicher das Zehnfache.
Für André Oggiers Reben
reicht es also nicht.
Hier oben ist es schon trocken.
- Ja, hier ist es viel trockener.
Ein Schluck Wasser wäre schon gut.
- Hm?
Für die Neupflanzung wäre es
wichtig, jetzt wässern zu können.
Aber es ist eine schöne Ernte.
Langfristig allerdings
müssen die Bauern hier
auf verschiedenen Ebenen neu denken.
Man muss sich auch wieder
besser um die Böden kümmern,
sodass das Wasser
besser zurückgehalten wird.
Das sind alles Themen,
die jetzt aktuell sind.
Nicht nur Wasser geben,
sondern auch schauen,
dass es besser im Boden bleibt.
Kaum mehr einen Monat, oder?
- Nein, das nicht.
Auch politisch ist der Stein
ins Rollen gekommen.
Die ganze Region
arbeitet an einem grossen Projekt,
um das Bewässerungsproblem zu lösen.
* Glockige Klänge *
Mitte August in der Valzeina.
Auch hier ist das Wasser knapp.
Auf der Alp
dort hinten in der Senke,
kam letzte Woche nichts mehr,
kein Tropfen mehr.
Die neue Maschine, der Wider,
ist seit einem Monat in Betrieb.
Aber so ganz regelmässig
will er noch nicht.
* Hämmerndes Geräusch *
Jetzt funktioniert es.
Wir hatten am Anfang
ein kleines Problem:
Irgendwo gab es einen Wasserverlust.
Eine Dichtung war nicht ganz
angezogen oder nicht ganz dicht.
Dort gab es einen Wasserverlust.
Aber jetzt
funktioniert es glücklicherweise.
* Lautes hämmerndes Geräusch *
Dieses kleine Gerät soll fünf
neue Brunnen mit Wasser versorgen.
Dünser muss kontrollieren,
ob das Wasser oben auch ankommt.
Die Existenz der Bauern von Trimmis
hängt davon ab.
Wenn wir hier
die Alpung nicht hätten,
hätten wir im Winter
einfach zu wenig Futter.
Wir müssten uns eine andere
Betriebsform einfallen lassen
oder was weiss ich ...
Aber wir können nicht einfach
auf Gemüsebau umstellen,
dazu haben wir die Böden gar nicht.
430 Höhenmeter hinauf
wird das Wasser gepumpt,
auf die höchste Stelle der Alp.
* Perlende Klaviermusik *
Das Wasser kommt.
Das ist schon mal freudig.
Hier sollten jetzt ca. 2,5-3 l
Wasser pro Minute hinaufkommen.
Das sind rund 3'000 l pro Tag.
So sollte die Versorgung der Tiere
auf dieser Höhe gesichert sein.
Zuerst werden die Brunnen gefüllt.
Das Wasser, das jetzt hineinkommt,
läuft gleich weg.
Erst wenn die Brunnen voll sind,
staut es zurück.
Das ist dann das letzte Reservoir,
das gefüllt wird.
Früher mussten die Kühe,
wenn sie hier weideten,
bis nach ganz unten laufen,
um zu trinken.
Bis sie sich wieder
nach hier oben verschieben,
dauert es relativ lange.
Sie sind nicht so dumm,
zu weit weg vom Wasser zu gehen,
wenn es heiss ist.
* Perlende Klaviermusik *
Die meisten Kühe
haben sich weiter unten
um den vollen Brunnen versammelt.
Dieser wird jetzt
vom obersten gespiesen.
Aus dem Hahn käme hier auch
diesen Sommer viel zu wenig Wasser.
Das ist das,
was aus der Quelle kommt.
Ich würde sagen,
hier kommt jetzt ein knapper Liter.
Das reicht natürlich niemals für
all die Tiere, die jetzt hier sind.
Wie schön es ist,
wenn das Wasser immer läuft,
merkt man erst,
wenn es mal nicht mehr läuft.
Wir sind uns gar nicht gewohnt,
was das heisst.
Ja, ja, ihr seid lustig.
Im Engadin ist Mitte August
der Schnee geschmolzen.
Glaziologe Felix Keller schaut,
wie es um sein Experiment steht.
1,20 m.
Für zwei Jahre
ist das eigentlich gut.
Schon letztes Jahr hatte er
direkt neben dem Lischana-Gletscher
ein erstes Vlies ausgelegt,
um zu testen,
ob Snowfarming hier funktioniert.
Das ist genau,
was wir erwartet haben.
Dieses Vlies haben wir bereits
im letzten Sommer angebracht.
D.h. der Schnee darunter
ist nicht vom letzten Winter,
sondern vom vorletzten.
Das ist für mich der Beweis,
dass es möglich ist,
Schneereservoirs anzulegen,
die mit der Zeit
einen neuen Gletscher ergeben.
Wasser für die Lischana-Hütte
kommt aber nicht von hier,
sondern vom Gletscher
gleich nebenan.
Seit drei Wochen hängt der Schlauch
für die Hütte am Gletscherwasser.
Wir erwarten, dass der Gletscher
in den nächsten drei, vier Jahren
verschwinden wird -
endgültig verschwinden wird.
Dann hat die Hütte
kein Wasser vom Gletscher mehr.
Solange es den Gletscher gibt,
hat man mehr als genug,
ist der Gletscher weg,
hat man gar nichts mehr.
* Sanfte, perlende Klaviermusik *
100 Höhenmeter weiter unten, bei der
anderen Wasserfassung ist das Vlies,
das Keller im Juni ausgelegt hat,
als noch viel Schnee lag.
Eigentlich verrückt, dass wir so
2 m Schnee erhalten konnten.
Das ist die Schneemasse,
die wir für die Wasserversorgung
der Hütte brauchen können.
Um die Hütte zu versorgen,
wenn der Gletscher nicht mehr da ist,
bräuchte es
ein achtmal so grosses Vlies.
Das macht jedoch nur Sinn,
wenn die alte Wasserfassung,
die im Juni noch vereist war,
zuerst erneuert wird.
Keller versucht den Kanton
und die SAC-Sektion
für sein Projekt zu gewinnen.
Was man machen möchte,
um die Wasserfassung,
die offensichtlich
nicht mehr funktioniert,
wieder zum Funktionieren zu bringen,
ist,
dass man hier
ein sog. Y in den Boden bringt,
mit dem man das Wasser tiefgründig
fasst und unten abdichtet.
Denn hier versickert extrem viel.
Vielleicht kommen wir mit dem
Snowfarming auch noch etwas näher.
Dann kann man das Wasser
hier ganz gezielt sammeln
und im Schutt reinigen.
Das wäre eine gute Lösung
für die Hütte.
Unten in der Hütte
gibt es eine positive
und eine negative Nachricht.
Die positive:
Ursula Hofer hat Wasser aus dem Hahn.
Das ist nötig.
Sie hat viele Tagesgäste.
Eine Teekanne.
- Welchen Tee? Pfefferminze?
Pfefferminze.
- 1 l oder 1,5 l?
1 l reicht.
- 1 l. Sehr gern.
Danke.
- Danke.
Die negative Nachricht ist:
Sie jongliert nach wie vor
mit jedem Liter.
Das Gletscherwasser ist sandig
und muss immer noch abgekocht werden.
Nun hofft sie,
dass Kellers Projekt bewilligt wird.
Wenn nicht, könnte man die Hütte
nicht mehr bewartet führen.
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen,
hier jede Woche zehn Rotationen,
8'000 l Wasser hinaufzufliegen.
Das ist für die Wildtiere nicht gut,
die Hütte
verliert viel an Attraktivität.
Erstens der Lärm und die Abgase
und zweitens die ganzen Steinböcke
und Murmeltiere,
die für unsere Gäste so wichtig sind
als USP der Lischana.
Hier kann man jeden Tag
Steinböcke sehen.
Die wären dann weg, die bleiben
nicht, die wandern sicher ab.
* Sphärische, hölzerne Klänge *
Zurück ins Wallis:
Salgesch hat immer noch kein Wasser
aus der Raspille.
Wenn es nicht regnet,
kommt weiterhin das ganze Wasser
für die Landwirtschaft
von der Nachbargemeinde Varen.
Gert Glenz
kann nur noch ausnahmsweise
und bei dringendem Bedarf
Wasser verteilen.
Und das auch nur für kurze Zeit.
Jetzt geben wir diesen Gärten
Wasser.
Damit die wieder mal
gegossen werden können.
Es gibt hier auch Tiere:
Hühner, Hasen, Pferde.
Jetzt kann man deren Tränken
wieder mal füllen.
Dann gilt die Devise:
Man muss mit dem leben, was man hat.
Das ist ... ist so.
Wenigstens im Moment.
Im Gemeindehaus von Salgesch
allerdings werden grosse Pläne
für die Lösung des Wasserproblems
diskutiert.
Fünf Gemeinden wollen zusammen
das Schmelzwasser vom Frühling
in einem Stausee zwischenspeichern.
Das wäre neu für die Schweiz.
Bisher werden die Stauseen
nur zur Energiegewinnung genutzt.
Das Projekt Lienne-Raspille
ist für uns auch wichtig
für die weitere Bewässerung
oder Wassergarantie.
Hast du dazu noch
Zusatzinformationen?
Ja, das wird demnächst aufgelegt.
Wir konnten es mit dem Kanton
und dem Staatsrat diskutieren.
Die Signale sind positiv.
Das wird aufgelegt,
wir sind positiv unterwegs.
Ca va être très innovateur
et assez unique
de pouvoir faire ce projet
Lienne-Raspille.
C'est la situation maintenant.
Tu as utilisé les bons termes.
Das Projekt ist visionär
und revolutionär.
Die Idee, das Schmelzwasser im
Frühling zu sammeln und zu speichern
und in den Trockenperioden
dann zu brauchen,
ist eine fantastische Idee
mit einer positiven Auswirkung
auf die Natur,
denn die Reservoirs
sind ja bereits gebaut.
Das Schöne an diesem Projekt ist,
dass schon bestehende Installationen
da sind, die man nutzt.
Vielleicht müsste man
bei den neuen Konzessionen,
die man bei den Staudämmen vergibt,
schauen, dass man das Wasser
teilweise für die Bewässerung
brauchen könnte.
Und irgendwann einmal vielleicht
sogar als Trinkwasser.
60 Mio. Fr. dürfte das Vorhaben
etwa kosten,
und zehn Jahre
wird es sicher noch dauern,
bis es realisiert werden kann.
Bund und Kanton
finden es interessant,
v.a. auch,
weil es keinen Strom braucht.
Harald Glenz begleitet die Planung
schon seit fünf Jahren.
Die Idee ist,
dass man dieses Gebiet hier,
das Schmelzwasser,
das hier im Frühling anfällt,
über eine Verbindung
in den See bringt.
Und dann wie jetzt, im Herbst,
September, Oktober,
später vielleicht
sogar schon mal im Juli,
über tieferliegende Leitungen
in dieses Gebiet bringt,
sodass man die Gemeinden
Varen, Salgesch, Miège, Venthône,
Veyras, Siders zurückspeisen könnte.
Er will sich selbst ein Bild machen
und schaut die Situation
von oben an.
* Klagende Streichmusik *
Hier war früher der Gletscher.
Dahinter, aus dem Bassin,
speiste der Gletscher über die Kuppe
die Raspille.
Jetzt hat er sich zurückgezogen.
Es ist eindrücklich,
wie nahe das Glück eigentlich wäre.
Und doch so weit weg.
Die Idee des Projekts ist,
dass man versucht,
das Wasser solange wie möglich oben
zu behalten, so hoch wie möglich.
Deshalb versucht man,
die bestehenden Anlagen zu nutzen,
wie z.B. den Stausee in Tseuzier.
Man sieht, dass er in der Zeit,
in der man das Wasser braucht,
ziemlich viel Wasser liefern könnte.
Im dümmsten Fall
liefert er in diesem Moment
vielleicht weniger
für die Energieproduktion,
dafür mehr für die Landwirtschaft
und mehr Trinkwasser.
Und im Frühling mehr
für die Stromproduktion.
Ich bin der Meinung,
dass man Stauseen künftig generell
nicht mehr nur
für die Energieproduktion nutzt,
sondern auch
für die Wasserversorgung generell.
Das wird etwas kosten,
das ist ganz klar.
Aber kein Wasser
kostet noch viel mehr.
Es ist Mitte September.
In der Valzeina
geht die Alpsaison zu Ende.
* Perlende Klaviermusik *
Reto Dünser setzt die Zäune tiefer,
damit die Kühe sich ins Tal bewegen.
Für ihn war es ein guter Sommer.
Der Wider hat funktioniert.
Wir haben ja zwei Anlagen gebaut.
Die eine hat wunderbar funktioniert,
die andere hat etwas Luft erwischt.
Dann weiss sie nicht mehr, was tun,
und schaltet sich aus.
Aber wir konnten sie
immer laufen lassen,
die Brunnen wurden gefüllt
und so kamen wir über die Runden.
Sonst wäre es sicher knapp geworden.
Er ist auf dem Weg
zu seinen Kollegen von der Alperza.
Im Herbst müssen die Weiden
entbuscht werden.
Weil die Kühe
wegen des fehlenden Wassers
oben nicht mehr richtig
geweidet haben,
ist das Gebiet
teilweise zugewachsen.
Das Gras
bildet mit den Jahren Horste.
Es ist hart und sauer
und fast messerscharf.
Das fressen sie einfach nicht mehr.
Wenn man nichts tut, passiert es,
dass die Heidelbeeren kommen.
Dann haben wir am Schluss
gar nichts mehr.
Wenn wir es auf die Grasnarbe
zurücksetzen können,
kann es wieder neu wachsen.
Dann fressen sie es auch wieder.
Wir von der Alp haben einen Vertrag
mit dem Kanton, dem Bund,
was die Biodiversität angeht.
Wir sind verpflichtet, etwas zu tun,
damit die bestehende Situation
sicher so bleibt.
Noch besser wäre,
wenn sie sich noch verbessern würde.
Marcel Räber und Margrit Montsch
sind beide Mitglieder der Alperza
und schon seit Stunden dran,
zu roden.
Sie hatten ihre Kühe -
gleich wie Reto Dünser -
den Sommer über hier oben.
Heidelbeeren und Alpenrosen -
alles weg.
Erosionsgefahr
entsteht dadurch nicht.
Die Grasnarbe unten
verletzen wir nicht, die bleibt.
Wenn wir hier das Kraut
oder die Büsche wegnehmen,
hat es überall noch Gras darunter,
das das Ganze zusammenhält.
Da wird nichts passieren.
Wir gehen nicht hinauf
in die Steillagen.
Dort könnte es Erosion geben.
Aber ich bin überzeugt:
Solange die Tiere hier sind, haben
wir auch die Erosion besser im Griff
als wenn keine Tiere mehr da sind.
Und solange es einen Konsens gibt,
dass die Alpen
beweidet werden sollen,
werden Reto Dünser und
andere Bergbauern alles dafür tun,
die Weiden zu erhalten.
Der Aufwand jedoch ist enorm.
Es gehört zu unserem Berufsstand,
dass wir halt räumen, entbuschen.
Das ist wirklich zeitintensiv
und streng.
Aber wir machen das für unsere
Zukunft und die Zukunft der Jungen.
Ich glaube, es muss ein Gefühl
für die Alpen dahinterstecken,
man muss Freude an ihnen haben.
Im Wallis ist die Traubenernte
Mitte September bereits voll im Gang.
Rund einen Monat früher als üblich.
* Sanfte Gitarrenmusik *
Wie viele Kisten
machst du pro Linie?
Etwa zweieinhalb bis drei Kisten.
Nicht gerade viel.
- Nein.
Knapp 700 g pro Meter.
- Ja.
Aber es ist nicht so,
dass die Reben Wassermangel hatten?
Es ist nicht nur wegen des Wassers,
oder?
Nein, es ist die extreme Hitze,
die während des ganzen Sommers
herrschte.
Und diese Woche
war es jeden Tag über 30 °C.
Ja, Bikini-Wetter.
Wahnsinnig.
- Viele Trauben sind extrem klein.
Ja, die Beeren sind extrem klein,
wie Heidelbeeren,
einfach nicht gewachsen.
Man hat das Gefühl, es ist ein wenig
wie im Süden, in Spanien usw.
Der Wein, den sie dort haben ...
Sie haben auch wenig Wasser.
Extrem heiss und trocken.
Es geht ein wenig in diese Richtung.
Dieses Klima
kommt hier auch immer mehr.
Das wird die Sorten wohl auch etwas
aussortieren.- Wahrscheinlich.
Mal schauen, wie sich die nächsten
Jahre entwickeln werden.
Es ist fraglich, ob es dann
immer noch dieselben Sorten sind.
Ja, es ist fraglich,
wie es weitergeht.
Wenig Wasser, höhere Temperaturen,
kleinere Trauben.
Normalerweise dürfen die Winzer
1,2 kg Trauben
pro Quadratmeter Reben abliefern.
Dieses Jahr fällt die Ernte
um ein Viertel kleiner aus.
Und es gibt
noch ein anderes Problem.
Die Ernte kommt immer früher.
Früher erntete man bis im November.
Mitte September ist ein Grossteil
der Ernte schon vorbei.
Die Pflanzen
sind danach immer noch grün.
Früher
waren sie danach praktisch ...
Man ging nicht mehr in die Reben.
Was wird damit passieren?
Braucht es danach immer noch Wasser?
Das wird schwierig.
Am Klima können sie nichts ändern,
aber wenn man künftig Stauseen
als Zwischenspeicher
für die Landwirtschaftsbewässerung
nutzen könnte,
würde das hier
und auch an anderen Orten helfen.
Irgendeine Lösung
wird man immer finden,
die Walliser Rebbauern
sind pragmatisch.
Nein, aufhören ist kein Thema.
Auf die Zähne beissen und hoffen,
dass bessere Zeiten kommen.
Aber wir geben sicher nicht auf,
das ist kein Thema.
* Melancholische Klaviermusik *
Beim Lischana-Gletscher werden die
Schatten im September wieder länger.
Hüttenwartin Ursula Hofer
macht ihre wöchentliche Runde.
Ich gehe immer der Leitung entlang,
egal wo ich war, um nachzuschauen.
Es kann sein,
dass mal eine Kupplung aufgeht.
Wenn die Nächte sehr kalt sind,
friert die Leitung ein.
Das bisschen Sonne reicht nicht,
dass es wieder auftaut.
Dann gibt es
keinen Wasserzufluss zur Hütte mehr.
Bis dann ist und bleibt
ihre einzige Wasserquelle
die Fassung am Gletscherbach, die
die Hütte seit Mitte Juli versorgt.
Ohne das Wasser vom Gletscher ...
... können wir dort
gar nichts mehr machen.
Aber es rinnt jetzt schon
um einiges weniger an Wasser
als noch vor einer Woche.
Weil es einfach schon
viel kälter geworden ist
durch den Sonnenstand
jetzt im September.
1850 ging der Gletscher noch
hinunter bis zur Lischana-Hütte.
Das riesige Schotterfeld, das er
hinterlassen hat, ist eindrücklich.
Wir haben mal
einen Tourenbericht gefunden
von einer Fahrt auf den Piz Lischana
aus dem Jahr 1872.
Sie gingen dem Gletscher entlang
auf der Seite hinauf
und dann auch, so wie jetzt,
auf den Pass und dann über den Grat.
Links und rechts vom Grat
war geschlossene Gletscherfläche.
Der Autor hat geschrieben:
"Rund um uns 5 km2 Eis."
Wenn man sich vorstellt,
dass das Ganze bis hier oben ...
... 300 Höhenmeter dick Eis war,
ist das unglaublich.
Das ist alles weg,
das haben wir alles
irgendwie verbraucht.
Ursula Hofer muss die Wasserleitung
für den ersten Schneefall
vorbereiten.
Jede Kupplung hat einen Steinmann,
damit wir sie finden,
wenn Schnee darauf liegt.
Ihre Hoffnung,
dass Felix Keller hier
mithilfe von Snowfarming einen
künstlichen Gletscher aufbauen kann,
ist im Moment getrübt.
Das Projekt ist zwar mittlerweile
von der SAC-Sektion finanziert
und von der Gemeinde abgesegnet,
aber der Kanton
hat Auflagen gemacht.
Der Kanton verlangt zuerst
eine Sanierung der Kläranlage,
bevor wir
irgendetwas anderes machen.
Ich verstehe es zwar nicht ganz.
Ohne Wasserfassung brauchen wir
auch keine neue Kläranlage mehr.
Denn wenn das mit dem Wasser
nicht funktioniert,
gibt es eh keinen Betrieb mehr
auf der Hütte.
Und dann
erübrigt sich das eigentlich.
So schnell wie möglich
nehmen sie jetzt
die Projektierung der Kläranlage
in Angriff.
Im besten Fall
können sie nächstes Jahr
hier mit Snowfarming
im grossen Stil beginnen.
Richtig kalt ist es hier drin.
Wie ein Kühlschrank.
Es sieht schon vielversprechend aus,
das Ganze.
Das ist schon faszinierend.
Das ist ganz schön hoch.
Ich bin auch schon 1,80 m gross.
Also, gut.
Wenn es klappt, könnte dies auch zum
Modell für andere SAC-Hütten werden.
Wenn ich mir hier vorstelle,
was der Inn, der Rhein und die Donau
alles mitnehmen,
geht es über ein paar Tausend
Kilometer weiter.
Das Wasser der Gletscher,
das täglich
Menschen mit Wasser versorgt.
Irgendwann
sind wir darauf angewiesen,
dass es regelmässig regnet,
weil wir keine Gletscher mehr haben.
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
M. Gassner, S. Näpflin - 2020